let's talk about cannabis as many in our
audience want me to describe it others
refer to it as marijuana some call it
pot some call it weed but I am told the
right way to discuss it is talking about
cannabis last week I told you that the
Massachusetts alcohol and bar Lobby is
big league fear mongering against
cannabis legalization they put out this
insane ad absurdities that make no sense
critiques against marijuana all of which
would be made could be made much more
strongly against the alcohol industry
itself and we said well there must be
some connection between the expected
revenues for alcohol in connection with
or related to the legalization of
cannabis well there is now a really
really interesting report through
Deloitte called recreational marijuana
insights and opportunities which says
that legalized recreational cannabis in
Canada would create a bigger than twenty
two billion dollar industry which would
exceed the combined sales of beer wine
and spirits and to satisfy this Canadian
market six hundred thousand kilograms of
cannabis would need to be grown yearly
now for comparison there are currently
36 licensed medical marijuana growers in
Canada we are talking huge numbers here
and like in the US a lot of the same
issues are being discussed the effects
on health road safety issues criminal
justice issues exploring the financial
implications and more and there's really
no answer other than money as to why we
are seeing this Lobby and you speculated
about this Pat that the impact of legal
cannabis on alcohol and I think you also
mentioned cigarettes you're probably
going to see alcohol sales and cigarette
sales decrease if you have legal
cannabis and that tells us everything in
connection with this study from Deloitte
that's why the alcohol industry is so
fixated on keeping cannabis illegal
because it's going to affect their
market and in Canada the report predicts
more a bigger market being created for
legal cannabis
what currently exists for alcohol you
follow the money you usually get to the
answer and you have to wonder if all
this money was already being generated
by the black market and now the public's
just seeing the benefit or if the fact
that it because it's legal now and seen
as more legitimate that's creating a
whole new wave of users for the product
and normal disclaimers here weed isn't
some miracle drug with no downsides
smoking anything is bad for your lungs
regardless of whether CBD or THC have X
Y or Z effect on whatever health
condition you want to study but think
about the insanity of the situation
hundreds of peer-reviewed medical
studies regarding possible and likely
medicinal benefits and insanely
upside-down criminal justice system
insofar as the war on drugs is concerned
disproportionate and racially tinged
application of drug laws including
against nonviolent users in the US and
then the financial angle for states it's
all nuts and the more we learn about the
financial implications like this report
from Deloitte the more we understand why
this is going to be fought against by
powerful and well-funded industries if
you think for a second about what legal
cannabis is up against huge funding
source the seizures of marijuana and
property in cash etc for local police
departments huge funding source for the
DEA and federal agencies big pharma is
against the legalization of cannabis for
obvious reasons in that hey if this
actually turns out to be a valid
treatment for either symptoms or
conditions that's going to be bad for
the pharmaceutical industrial complex
the alcohol industry the cigarette lobby
none of these industries none of these
organizations none of these apparatus
want to see cannabis legalized I still
believe eventually it will happen and
individual states like the handful of
states that on November 8th have a
question a ballot initiative we're going
in the right direction but if you look
at the odds are really stacked against
this in a lot and with big money yet
from what we've seen in the five states
voting on legal recreational marijuana
it's leading in all five what we saw
with gay marriage is state-by-state they
would legalize it and then the Supreme
Court looked at the whole issue yeah
and decided to to pass it for the whole
country we're not going to see that with
marijuana because it's not considered as
much of a legal right no I mean we you
you it got to the point with same-sex
marriage where it just became clear that
at the state level these individual bans
on same-sex marriage are not
constitutional the Supreme Court got
involved and decided that when you're
talking about legal cannabis it's harder
to argue that there's some kind of
inherent rights to legal cannabis so I
don't believe we're going to see a
Supreme Court decision on legal cannabis
but that what's the goal right it's
basically twofold if enough states say
we are legalizing cannabis we're
legalizing and regulating it not
unregulated ideally you would see a
decision made by the President and by
Congress that will involve federal
agencies well they were they will say we
are now going to completely leave this
as an issue to the states or we are just
going to reschedule cannabis and we're
going to stop the federal ban or federal
illegality of cannabis because so many
states have spoken about this in a
democratic way that's the dream I guess
you would say and we we you know we've
been following it and we're going to
continue to follow it in the meantime
what you can do is if you're in one of
the states that has a ballot initiative
on this on November 8th vote in favor of
decriminalization or legalization and if
you're in a state that does not have
that on the ballot start working on a
ballot initiative for the next election